one person who did not blow her game
however is katarina m silva which i uh
let me just get that final position on
my screen who we have in studio she's
had a fantastic performance so far going
plus three with no losses katarina you
must be thrilled with your performance
up to the stage yes i think i'm still
processing that i actually won a game
after so many draws
so i'm very happy
now given that
you did have a weird opening you played
knight b3
in the opening which
we weren't it's not a main line
[Laughter]
no we were certainly confused to see
this move and especially queen e7 would
have given you some fits in this
position so megan kind of tricked me and
she went knight f6 which was very
unexpected i was expecting like early to
go that she's gonna go bishop c5 which
she played here so i wanted to treat her
back the problem was i wasn't sure about
my lines i see because castles is the
normal move uh that that was played over
5 000 times your move was played about
30 times because i wanted to stop c5 i
mean the movement makes sense but
i don't know if queen e7 if it's
tactically wrong no castles castles is
just the line that's just the main line
but knight b3 would allow queen e7 and
and you will be on skates almost
immediately well thankfully she played
very solidly and we predicted she would
play solidly with bishop e7 and castles
which seemed very normal but then you
started out playing her and got the
typical advantage in this in this
opening so you dominated
you must have felt good when you finally
got a pawn on e7 yes that was a very
good feeling i was not sure about my
knight c3 move but i remember when i was
actually analyzing my previous game with
talia i should have got to this
structure but i didn't go for it because
i wasn't sure how strong it is so i
analyzed it a little bit more and now i
was like oh i can have the structure
again and like repeat and improve so i
thought this is better but i wasn't sure
how big of an advantage i have here
because black is very solid
right so you got to to go through and
then she played
uh as sharp as she could but soon this
pawn
got now h6 is a blunder according to the
engines and e7 as well
i thought it's the point that i can push
the pawn
hard to imagine
exactly why that would be a mistake
i can imagine queen f7 perhaps was that
a main move for you queen f7 that i can
always capture and take on c6 and 98 are
threats
i'm not sure not sure
the e7 certainly has my attention the
engine's saying e7 can be measured by
bishop by king 87 king h when as played
that's that bishop d4 was a mistake but
instead bishop
f5 was better and still holding
apparently which
if we're confused then it doesn't matter
it would have
turkey never takes d4 i have a very nice
like uh structure because the bone on e7
is fantastic right but then at some
moment i was like wait is there like a
fourth rest then i cannot actually push
through but luckily i had the h4h5 yes
exactly
i was a little bit uh scolding you here
for playing c3 i know i know i mean you
just all you have to do is uh establish
a rook on fa the c2 pawn as it turns out
obviously gotcha with your bishop
lording over the position on c5 but even
c3 bishop e4 and then rook f1 instead of
king james thank you christian you're on
my side no of course this is still
completely winning right it is
completely winning even c3 doesn't but
with c3 bishop before now king g1 i
think was the loss of temple which is
quite important because you can go
you can
i was scared after rook f1 she's gonna
go something like uh rook b8 and now i
cannot go rook f8 because of checkmate
guys it's all winning it's all winning
anyway it's all winning all of it all of
it all of it a big win for you you're
half a point out of first keeping the
pressure on carissa who had a big win
today as well
you got three rounds with a rest day
you've been telling us just play my best
but you're only three rounds from
winning a championship yeah it's working
i mean i'm surprised by my play i'm
definitely not complaining very happy
i'm so happy there is a res day tomorrow
because i'm exhausted yesterday's game
with was extremely exhausting today as
well so i really needed that extra day
you get black against arena and you get
black against carissa that's going to be
a tall order
big challenge
it's okay whatever i get i'm going to
play my best all right congratulations
and good luck the rest of the way thank
you absolutely our congratulations to
gotcha very fine performance indeed